Speaker 1: Speaking of Trump and Twitter and
social media, it turns out Trump is actually
wanting to get back on Facebook and start
tweeting. On Twitter, of course, this account
has been brought back on Twitter, but he has not
tweeted yet. And he's also lobbying to get back on
Facebook here from NBC News. Mounting a comeback
for the White House. Donald Trump is looking to
regain control over his powerful social media
accounts with access to his Twitter account back.
Trump's campaign is formally petitioning Facebook
parent company to unblock his account there after
it was locked in response to the US Capitol riot
two years ago. Quote, Trump is probably coming
back to Twitter. It's just a question of how and
when, said a Republican who spoke on condition
of anonymity to discuss private conversation with
Trump about returning to the platform. He's been
talking about it for weeks, but Trump speaks for
Trump, so it's anyone's guess what he'll do or say
or when. Another Trump confidant who also didn't
want to be identified speaking about conversations
with him, said that Trump has sought input for
weeks about hopping back on Twitter and that his
campaign advisers have also workshopped ideas for
his first tweet. And then Facebook has not given a
direct answer yet, but it seemed likely that they
might let him back on. And so he shortly could
be active on Twitter and Facebook. Once again,
here's a bit of this being discussed, um, on CNN.
Speaker 2: Where President Donald Trump's campaign
petitioning Facebook to unblock his account. That,
of course, remember the social media giant
locked it in response to the January six
riot at the Capitol. Let's bring in
CNN's Christiane hold. She's following
this story for us. Kristen, tell us more.
Speaker 3: So, John, as we know, Facebook's ban
was not indefinite. And as we reported last week,
the metal the parent group was already having
meetings deliberating whether or not they were
going to let former President Trump back on its
site. In fact, they were taking it so seriously.
They had a small working group within the company
that was working on that. But now it appears that
the campaign is trying to accelerate that process.
They sent a letter to Mehra asking for Trump to be
reinstated and to have a meeting with that parent
company. Now, I want to read you one expert
excerpt of why they say they think that they
should be reinstated, says Donald J. Trump. They
declared candidate for president of the United
States. We believe the ban on President Trump's
account on Facebook has dramatically distorted and
inhibited the public discourse. Moreover, every
day that President Trump's political voice remains
silenced furthers an inappropriate interference
in the American political and election process.
Speaker 1: So why does this matter? Well, if
you kept up with politics pre and post Trump's
social media bans, you remember the significant
nature of how that affected his ability to use his
megaphone, use his voice to craft and influence
the public discourse, the daily conversations.
And yet now he's untruth, social and occasionally
says stuff, or he's constantly saying stuff. We
occasionally cover it, but it's not the same as
what he had his voices on Twitter and Facebook,
but Twitter most significantly. And so
whether or not he starts tweeting again,
whether or not Facebook allows him back on will
actually affect the next two years and the voice
that he has in his presidential campaign and
how he's able to leverage that in different
ways in a very significant way. And so it's
fascinating to watch. It's weird and strange
to try to understand why now it makes sense if.
The past actions that he got banned for didn't
change. Why now? It makes sense to bring them
back. Who knows? But it seems likely that will
indeed occur and we will continue to keep up
with it. Follow me on twitter. Luke p beasley